la ballon
[Applaudissements]
merci de votre participation
on a survécu tous les services d'urgence
et de secours ont été rétablies
tout crime y compris celui d'homicides
est désormais illégal avait
nui seulement mais reste de l'année
c'est calme
et des mois
dépité
non elle continue
c'est dingue ils n'ont pas entendu les
sirènes le crime ça existe plus
tout est permis les riches peuvent plus
cacher derrière leurs rideaux de fer
vous êtes faibles ça fait quoi c'est la
vraie purge la purge sans limite
il arrive
année suivez moi
il n'y a aucun endroit sûr
aucune chance d'être secoués
tiens vous trouver un autre moyen de
s'enfuir
ce pays va s'effondrer
le mexique rouvre sa frontière pendant
les six prochaines heures
on va les soutenir
[Musique]
vva
destiné cette pourriture tu la fermes
sinon
[Musique]
sinon j'étais quoi